thousands of cp rail workers across the
country are off the job a labor dispute
grinding a major part of the supply
chain to a halt farmers and dozens of
other industries are warning the impacts
of a protracted work stoppage could be
catastrophic john spector has more
these canadian pacific rail workers in
calgary montreal and port coquitlam bc
are just a fraction of the 3 000 on the
picket line across the country after the
teamsters union and cp failed to reach
an agreement the company unfortunately
wasn't really in the in the mood to
negotiate with us so
here we are
the two sides have been in contract
talks since september each is blaming
the other for the dispute and for
causing the work stoppage but as
negotiations continue in calgary with
the assistance of federal mediation and
conciliation services people like
saskatchewan wheat farmer daryl franciux
are holding their breath the global food
supply is
is in jeopardy and this just doesn't
help cp ships roughly half of all
western canadian grain 75 of fertilizer
in canada is moved by rail farmers here
are now in limbo put the blame on the
unions and normally i don't do that but
i just see it as greed on their part
unfortunately 45 canadian business
groups signed a letter last week calling
for binding arbitration saying a
stoppage could do irrevocable damage to
canadian supply chains in the context of
covit exploding commodity prices and
soaring inflation the union blames the
company for creating even more
insecurity while cp says the teamsters
acted irresponsibly by going on strike
before responding to their last offer
it's work conditions
a more stable work schedule
obviously like everybody else there is
the salary aspect of things the house of
commons resumes monday after a two-week
break and many industry leaders are
hoping the first order of business is
back to work legislation these kinds of
things like the blockades that happened
at the various border crossings these
really undermine our reputation as that
sort of reliable
trading partner labor minister seamus
o'regan is in calgary keeping a close
eye on discussions you know everybody
would agree can't go on very long
you know like i said there's just no
appetite in the country for this right
now o'regan is not committing to back to
work legislation saying the pressure is
on the parties involved every hour that
goes by is an hour too long for
manufacturers and for farmers in this
country dan specter global news ottawa